Je suis Vince et tout est en eux, nous
allons partager avec vous une scène de notre
nouveau film le stage oh et c'est
l'interview alors euh d'accord rapprochez-
le de près ici nous
interviewons des navires chez Google et un
Google Hangout, nous ne sommes pas habitués à cela,
mais ici, allez-y et regardez-le, il
y a beaucoup de choses à faire là-dessus, c'est comme ça que les
gens le font maintenant Nicky, ils ont leurs
interviews sur Internet, allez, nous
pouvons vous voir les gars d'accord bon vous l'avez compris salut
je m'appelle Billy on t'entend bien aussi
oh super Oh Billy McMahon
Nick Campbell je suis Benjamin Allison on
va te poser quelques questions que certains
de nos candidats trouvent un peu bizarres
allons-y pas ton jugement tire sur toi '  re
rétréci à la taille de nickels et
tombé au fond d'un mélangeur que
faites-vous vous la prenez à plat sur votre
droite vous venez de vous allonger et une fois que ce
mélangeur est allumé pour toujours,
respectueusement, je dois être en désaccord, nous avons vendu des
mélangeurs et même  le meilleur mannequin du
monde va seulement  courir peut-être 10 ou 11
heures donc nous sortons et quand nous le
faisons, nous sommes mieux parce
que tout ce qui ne vous tue pas vous rend
plus fort, ce n'est pas tellement sortir
du mélangeur, c'est ce qui se passe ensuite
c'est la question que vous vous posez  J'ai deux
hommes de la taille d'un nickel libres dans le monde,
pensez aux possibilités, je veux dire, je me suis cassé la
tête et je gagne juste la réparation de lunettes de soleil,
peut-être que vous nous collez dans ces
sous-marins qu'ils mettent dans le corps des gens
pour combattre les
maladies  une vraie chose les sous-marins
attendez une minute je pensais que nous étions coincés dans
un mélangeur maintenant nous sauvons des vies quoi
quoi quoi quoi laissez-moi juste récapituler ça
pour vous très vite nous commençons et je
mets ouais je sauve des vies quoi quoi quoi
quoi attendre une minute nous étions coincés dans un
mélangeur et bien sûr maintenant nous sauvons des vies
sages nous a conduit à ceci merci